>> I AM SO EXCITED TO DO THIS.
TO TALK ABOUT CANNABI AND VIVIOA
WITH AI.
I ALREADY KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT
THE GREAT STORY WITH YOUR
GRANDMA AND HOW SHE GOT YOU INTO
IT.
I KNOW YOUR AMAZING STORY.
SO I WANT TO GET INTO MORE OF
THE NITTY-GRITTY STUFF, STARTING
WITH WHY WE ARE CALLING IT
CANNABIS.
BECAUSE I AUTOMATICALLYANT TO
SAY WEED.
BUT I KNOW IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE'RE DESTIGMATIZING THAT
AND CALLING IT CANNABIS.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT WHY THAHAT I.
>> YEAH.
THAT'S JUST PART OF THE INDUSTRY
EVOLVING, BEING ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
AS WE GO INT ROOMS AND TALK TO
CHURCH LEADERS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT, WE HAVE TO CALL IT
CANNABIS.
>> I KNOW FOR YOU, YOU HAVE
PROBABLY LEARNED SO MUCH ABOUT
THIS PROCESS OF GETTING INTO
CANNABIS.
WHAT IS THE NUMBER ONE THING
YOU'VE LEARNED SO FAR?
>> THE POSITIVE THINGS.
>> SEE, WE GOT YOU.
THE POSITIVE THINGS THAT AL
EXPLAINED TO ME WHAT ITT DOES AD
KILLING THE STIGMA.
COMING UP, IT WAS A BAD THING
AND JUST HEARING ALL THE
POSITIVE THINGS WHEN AL WAS
EDUCATING M ME ON THE CANNABIS.
AND, YOU KNOW, I'M A ROOKIE
RIGHT NOW AT IT, YOUOU KNOW WT I
MEAN?
BUT, YOU KNOW, A COUPLE YEARS
FROM NOW, YOU KNOW, I'LL
PROBABLY KNOW MORE THAN HIM.
>> YEAH, I LOVE IT.
WE'VE GOT SOME PREMIUM FLOWER
RIGHT HERE.
AND I SAID TO MY PRODUCER,
YOU'RE QUITE LITERALLY GETTING
YOUR FLOWER.
TELL ME ABOUT THIS STRAIN, AI.
>> SO I'LL TELL YOU MORE ABOUT
IT.
>> HE KNOWS ALL THAT.
I CAN DO IT THE --
>> SO THIS PROCESS STARTED
PROBABLY ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF
AGO, TO BE ON EFFORT, TO BE ABLE
TO CREATE A STRAIN FROM SCRATCH,
IT TAKES ABOUT A YEAR.
WE HAVE REALLY GOOD PARTNERS
CALL GREEN DRAGON.
MY VP OF STRATEGY, STEPHANIE, IS
THE ONE THAT HELPED ME CURATE
THIS RAIN.
I ASKED HIM WHAT HE WAS LIKE,
WHAT IS H HIS FVOR PROFILE AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
HE SAID YOU KNOW I LIKE
CHAMPAGNE.
WHEN WE HEARD THAT, I'M
INKING, OKAY, THAT MEANS WE
HAVE TO HAVE SOME TYPE OF GRAPE,
RIGHT?
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT OUR CULTURE
AND CANNABIS, A LOT OF THE
EXOTIC LEAVES AND DIFFERENT
THINGS LIKE THAT, IT LOOKS
PURPLE.
DIFFERENT THINGS LIKE THAT..
SOE CAME UP WITH GRAPE
STOMPER.
AND WHAT I I ALSO THOUGHT ABOUT-
BECAUSE THIS IS A CULTURE PLATE
FOR US BECAUSE HE REPRESENTS
CULTURE.
SO W WOULD HE VE BEEN VERY
SPECIFIC IN REGARDS OF WHO WE'RE
REALLY GOING AFTER WITH THIS
GENETICS.
AND SO WE WERE ABLE TO DO THIS
GRAPE STOMPING AND ATTEST FOR
ANYWHERE FROM 36 TO 32% THC.
IT WILL SIT YOU DOWN.
AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
MINT AND THE GRAPE FLAVORING, IT
TASTES A BIT LIKE CHAMPAGNE.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I'M
SAYING THAT IS OUR INTENT, BUT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT REACHED TOUT ME AND SAID
THIS TASTES LIKE A GLASS OF
CHAMPAGNE.
WITH IT BEING HIS FIRST STRAIN
AND WE'RE CALLING IT 96 AND WE
THINK ABOUT WHAT HE REPRESENTED
WHEN HE CAME IN IN '96, IT WAS A
GAME CHANGER, CHANGED THE GAME
FOREVER.
ON THE COURT AND OFF THE COURT.
AND NOTNLY FOR HIMSELF, BUT
EVEN FOR EVERY ATHLETE THAT
PLAYED IN THE LEAGUE BECAUSE AT
THAT P POINT IS WHEN GUYS START
REALIZINGHAT THIS CORPORATE
LIFE THAT THEY WANTED US TO
LIVE, THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE TO
LIVE THAT, WE COULD ACTUALLY BE
OURSELVES AND STILL BE THE STAR
OF THE SHOW.
SO I THINK OF ALL OF THOSE
THINGS.
>> AND I WOULD HAVE JUST SAID I
WANTED IT TO TASTE LIKE DOM P.
AND HAD TO BE STRONG GAS.
>> WAS THAT ACCOMPLISHED?
>> I THINK SO.
>> WANTO TALK ABOUT THE ROLE
OF WE'D
OF WEED IN THE NBA.
LAST YEAR THEY SUSPENDED RANDOM
TESTING UP FOR CANNABIS.
DO YOU SEE THAT DATE COMING
POTENTIALLY?
>> I THINK IT'S NOW.
IT'S ALREADY HAPPENED.
>> YOU HAD THE -- WHAT IS IT,
THE BUBBLE?
HAD ALL O LAST SEASON AND HAD
THAT SEASON STARTING.
THEY'RE NOT ADDRESSING IT.
THEY'RE NOT SAYING WRE TAKING
IT OFF THE LIST, THEY'RE JUST
SAYING WE SUSPENDED IT.
I WOULD GIVE THE PLAYERS A LOT
OF CREDIT THAT NONE OF THEM HAVE
ABUSED THIS OPPORTUNITY, WHICH I
DIDN'T THINK WE WOULD DO,
ANYWAY.
BECAUSE I ALWAYS SAY WE ALLAVE
ACCESS TO LIQUOR, RIGHT?
AND WHEN I KNOW I HAVE TO GO AND
GETTING DRUNK BEFORE I'M ABOUT
TO PLAY.
I'M NOT GOING TO GET HIGH BEFORE
I HAVE TO GO AT AI..
THINK ALL THE GUYS ARE VERY
PROFESSIONAL AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT.
AND I THINK THAT THESE GUYS HAVE
DONE A REALLY, REALLY GOOD JOB
AT TT ANDND BEI ABLE TO KEEP
IT SEPARATE.
THEY'RE USING, I KNOW FOR A
FACT.
>> FOR SURE.
100%.
AND IT'S A BEAUTIFUL THING.
IN THE PAST, IT'S ONLY BEEN
LIQUOR ORHARMACEUTICAL DRUGS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
WE ARE HUMAN BEINGS.
IF WHAT KIND OF PROBLEMS THEY
HAVE?
WE ACTUALLY HAVE MONEY.
>> WHICH HAS MORE PROBLEMS.
>> IT DOESN'T MAKE THINGS
EASIER.
GUYS, GREAT JOB AND I'M SO
HAPPY.
>> CAN I TALK ABOUT THE TIME IN
YOUR CAREER, BUT ABOUT IT BEING
OKAY, CANNABIS --
>> I PROBABLY DIDN'T HAVE A GOOD
PROGRAM THEN.
>> LIKE I SAID, IT WAS A STIGMA
THAT WAS SO BAD.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> WE SMOKED, YOU KNOW,
MARIJUANA AND IT WAS LIKE HE WAS
LABELED AS A VILLAIN, YOU KNOW
WHAT I MEAN, OR THE BAD GUY FOR
SMOKING.
AND THAT'S WHAT I REMEMBER THE
MOST.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN, THAT I HAD
TO GO THROUGH, YOU KNOW, WITH
THAT.
I HEAR PEOPLE IN THE CROROWD
CALLING ME WEED HEAD ON THE ROAD
AND STUFF LIKE THAT.
, YOU KNOW, IT WAS BAD.
BECAUSE I HAD -- WHEN I FIRST
GOT IT, WHEN I WAS A ROOKIE, I
HAD GOT STOPPED AND I HAD SOME
WEED ON ME.
AND I ACTUALLY WENT TO JAIL FOR
IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
ALL THESE YEARS LATER, LOOK
WHERE WE'RE AT.
>> THE PEOPLE WHO WANTED TO
WRITE A LETTER TO BUY IT IN, TO
HAVE HIM PARDON NONVIOLENT
OFFENDERS.
KIND OF HOW YOU SEE, AND A SHIFT
SOME SOME WAYS.
>> SINCE NEW YORK HAS MADE IT
LEGAL ARREST IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY, THEY'RE AT 95%.
>> INSANE.
>> 95%, AND THEN WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT
CANNABIS REPRESENTS THAT PART OF
THE POPULATION.
OBVIOUSLY THIS PARTNERSHIP AND
EVERYTHING THAT OLA S STANDSOR
IS ALL ABOUT CHANGING THE STIGMA
FIRST, YOU KNOW, CREATING MORE
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE CANNABIS
SPACE.
TO YOUR POINT, THERE'S BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS BEING MADE AND THE
PEOPLE MAKING IT DON'T LOOK LIKE
US.
CANNABIS WAS USED TO DESTROY OUR
COMMUNITY AND NOW, YOU KNOW,
THEY'R STILL KEEPING US OUT OF
IT, RIGHT, THROUGH ALL THESE
DIFFERENT REGULATIONS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
SO WE NEED TO CHANGE THAT
BECAUSE THERE'S A GENERATION OF
WEALTH AT RISK
THERE'S BEEN SO MANY OTHER
THINGS, INDUSTRIES THAT BLACK
PEOPLE HAVE PIONEERED.
>> I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
WINDOW DRESSING.
>> THEY'RE JUST SAYING IT.
>> AND IT'S JUST CHECKING A BOX.
SO WE'RE HERE TO KIND O PUT --
HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT
AND WE'RE TRYING TO DO IT
THROUGH OUR WORK, THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING ON A DAILY BASIS.
>> YOU GUYS ARE PIONEERS IN THIS
SPACE.
SHOUT OUT TO Y'ALL.
THIS IS SUPER, SUPER EXCITING.
SPEAK OF PIONEER, WE HAVE HUGE
PIONEER IN BASKETBALL.
I'VE BEEN SO EXCITED TO DO THIS
INTERVIEW.
AND YESTERDAY, I ACTUALLY CALLED
JAMES HARDEN BECAUSE I WAS
REALLY EXCITED.
I KNOW HOW MUCH HE RESPECTS YOU,
LOOKS UP TO YOU.
BUT I ASKED HIM IF HE HAD SOME
QUESTIONS THAT HE WANTED ME TO
ASK YOU.
AND HE -- WHEELS WERE TURNING.
HE'S LIKE, THERE'S SO MANY WAYS
I COULD GO.
AI HAS MEANT SO MUCH TO ME IN MY
LIFE.
I WANT TO ASK YOU SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT JAMES HAD FOR
YOU.
ALL RIGHT?
>> OKAY.
>> SO THE FIRST ONE, WHICH IS
SOMETHING I WANTED TO DELVE
INTO, AS WELL, HE SAID CAN YOU
ASK AI HOW OFTEN HE THINKS ABOUT
NOT HAVING A TITLE?
>> I NEVER THINK AUT IT.
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH.
I NEVER THIHINK ABOUT IT.
I CAME CLOSE, TRIED, BUT, YOU
KNOW, IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
BUT L ME TELL YOU WHY I DON'T.
LOOK WHAT GOD HAS DONE FOR ME.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I COME FROM THE MUD AND ENDED UP
BEING THE FIRST PICK IN THE
DRAFT OUT OF ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
IN THE WORLD, I'M THE NUMBER ONE
PICK IN THE WORLD.
ROOKIE OF THE CAREER.
THE MVMVP OF OUR LEAGUE.
ALL NBA.
ALL-STAR GAME MVP, OLYMPIAN, YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I'VE DONE SO MUCH, CHANGED THE
CULTURE IN BASKETBALL IN THE
NBA.
LOOK AT ALL THOSE BLESSINGS THAT
GOD DID FOR ME.
JUST GETTING DRAFTED WOULD HAVE
BEEN ENOUGH, YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEMEAN?
JUST BEING ON THE TEAM WOULDLD
VE BEEN ENOUGH.
BUT ALL THOSE ACCOLADES, ALL
THOSE THINGS THAT I WAS BLESSED
WITH, ALL THOSE ACCOMPLISHMENTS,
I DIDN'T WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP.
HE DIDN'T WANT THAT FOR ME.
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY HE WANTED
ALL THOSE OTHER THINGS FOR ME
AND HE MADE ME SO PROUD OF,
FIRST OF ALL, MYSELF BUT MY
MOM, MY DAD, THE PEOPLE THAT
RAED ME, ALL OF THE PEOPLE
THAT HELPED ME BECAUSE YOU DON'T
DO IT BY YOURSELF.
ALL THE PEOPLE THAT HELPED ME,
THE TTLE LEAGUE COACHES I HAD,
FROM LITTLE LEAGUE ALL THE E WA
UP TO, YOU KNOW, COLLEGE,
TEAMMATES, THE GUYS THAT SET THE
SCREENS FOR ME, PASS ME THE
BALL, THE TRAINERS, YOU KNOW
WHAT I MEAN.
THAT'S WHY WHEN I WENT UP THE
AND I TALKED ABOUT THE UPS AND
DOWNS THAT I WENT THROUGH IN M
LIFE, AS AN ATHLETE, A LOT OF
PEOPLE STUCK WITH ME.
A LOT OF PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, WENT
AWAY, BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE STUCK
WITH ME AND THAT'S WHAT IT
MEANT, WHY IT MEANT SO MUCH FOR
ME WHEN I WENT UP THERE AND SAID
NOW ALL AREALL OF FAMERS,
TOO, BECAUSE I AM.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> YEAH.
>> SO IT BOESHD ME THAT I DIDN'T
WIN O.
BUT I WON IN A LOT OF WAYS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
DO YOU ALL THINK WE MAY BE HAVE
TOO MUCH OF AN EMT ON RISKING
CULTURE?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
THAT'S THE ULTIMATE GOAL.
AND THAT SEPARATES THE BEST FROM
THE BEST.
IT DOES, YOU KNOW WHAT I MN?
AND THAT'S SOMETHING TOUGH
BECAUSE I GOT THERE, BUT I RAN
AGAINST, YOU KNOW, A JUGGERNAUT
WITH SHAQUILLE O'NEAL AND KOBE
BRYANT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I  MEAN?
THEY WERE SO GREAT THAT THEY
MADE EVERYBODY AROUND THEM, YOU
KNOW, SO MUCH BETTER.
AND, YOU KNOWOW, WE WERE A GRAT
TEAM, BUT WE GOT BEAT BY A
BETTER TEAM.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I CAN I HAD CHRIS PAUL ON MY
SHOW LAST YEAR, MAYBE THE YEARR
BEFORE THAT.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
CHAMPIONSHIPS AND HE'S LIKE, YOU
KNOW WHAT?
I WANT TO BE A CHAMPION IN LIFE.
LIKE, YOU KNKNKNOW, IT MEANS MOO
ME TO BE A GREAT HUSBAND, A
GREAT DAD.
I OBVIOUSLY WANT THAT BUT THERE
ARE SO MANY OTHER THINGS THAT I
AM PINING FOR, AS WELL.
>> AND THAT'S MY LITTLE MAN AND
I UNDERSTAND HIM WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
BUT PLAYING THAT GAME, THE
ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO WIN IT.
TO WIN IT ALL.
WE ALLLL WANT TO BE CHAMPIONS O
THE COURT.
WE ALWAYS -- WE WANT TO BE -- I
CAN'T STAND WHEN PEOPLE SAY, YOU
KNOW, I DON'T CARE ABOUT WHAT
NOBODY THINK ABOUT ME, WHATEVER.
WELL, I DO.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I DO.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO CALL ME OR
SAY ANYTHING TO ME THAT'S NOT
TRUE AND THINK IT'S NOT GOING TO
BOTHER ME.
BUT WE ALL WANT TO BE CHAMPIONS
LIFE.
WE ALWAYS WANT TO BE THE PEOPLE.
LIKE I ALWAYS SAY, YOU KNOW, I
CAN MAKE A MISTAKE.
I JUST DON'T WANT TO MAKE IT
TWICE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
SO WE ALWAYS WANT TO BE -- NOT
THE PERFECT PERSON,, BECAUSE
THERE'S NO LIFE BEING A PERFECT
PERSON BECAUSE YOU CAN'T LEAEAR
FROM THAT.
YOU CAN'T BE STRONG.
YOU CAN'T, YOU KNOW, OVERCOME.
YOU CAN'T DO ANY OF THOSE THINGS
AND TEST WHO YOU ARE AS A PERSON
IF YOU HAVAVE A PERFECT LIFE.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WE ALL WANT TO BE
CHAMPIONS OFF THE COURT, BUT
I -- WANTED TO BE ONE ON THE
COURT.
>> YEAH, I KNOW.
BUT THAT'S WHAT EVERYONE SAYS.
IT'S LIKE THAT MAN DESERVED A
RING.
HE REALLY, REALLY DID.
>> I FOUGHT FOR IT.
THAT'S THE OY THING THAT MAKES
ME FEEL GOOD AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
I CAN LOOK AT MYSYSELF ITHE
MIRROR AND KNOW THAT I PLAYED
EVERY GAME LIKE IT'S MY LAST.
>> THAT WAS ONE THING ON THE
ONE JAMES WAS SAYING RESINATES
WITH HIM SO MUCH WITH YOU AND
WHY HE FEELS LIKE THERE'S THIS
RELATEBILITY WITH YOU IS THAT HE
FEELS LIKE HE'S MISUNDERSTOOD.
HE FEELS LIKE HE IS MAYBE JUDGED
IN SOME WAYS.
AND HIS NEXT QUESTION WAS HOW DO
YOU THINK YOUR CAREER WOULD HAVE
BEEN DIFFERENT IF IT WAS LIKE
THIS SOCIAL MEDIA ERA, WHERE
EVERYONE HAS AN OPINION, THEY
CAN TALKK ABOUT Y ALL THE TIME.
>> WAY MORE OUT OF CONTROL.
OUT OF CONTROL.
AND I'M SO GLAD.
I'M SO GLAD, YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN?
MY INSTAGRAM, INSNSTEAD OF 10
MILLION, IT WOULD HAVE BEEN 50,
60, 100 MILLION.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
YOU NEVER KNOW.
BUT I WOULDN'T WANT TO TRADE THE
WAY IT IS RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN TOO OUT OF
CONTROL.
BACK THEN.
AND GOD KNOWS WHAT HE'S DOING.
SO I TRUST THAT PART RIGHT
THERE.
HE KNOWS WHAT HE'S DOING.
>> HOW SHOULD CURRENT NBA
PLAYS DL WITH BEING JUDGED
BY OTHERS?
>> YOU CONCENTRATE ON THE PEOPLE
THAT LOVE YOU.
AND THE NBA IS GOING TO BE --
WHAT MY OUTLOOK WAS, IT'S GOING
TO BE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE THAT
LOVE YOU.
PEOP THAT HATEOU.A MILLILION
NCENTRE ON THE ONES THAT
LOVE YOU.
YOU KN WHAT I MEAN?
THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE TO
CONCENTRATE ON.
IF, YOU KNOW, YOU CONCENTRATE ON
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE, THEN YOU ATE
GOT NO TIME TOO CONCENTRATE ON
THE ONE THAT'S HATE YOU.
SO YOU CONCENTRATE ON THE ONE
THAT'S LOVE YOU AND KNOW WHO YOU
ARE, BELIEVE IN WHO YOU ARE.
AND LOVE WHO YOU ARE.
YOU OW WHAT I MEAN?
I LOVE WHO I AM AS A MAN, AS A
PERSON, , AS THE PSON THAT I
EVOLVED INTO, THE FAMILY MAN,
THE FRIEND, THE BUSINESS
PARTNER.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LOVE BEING YOURSELF.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH BEING YOU?
EVERYBODY ELSE IN THE WORLD IS
TAKEN UP.
>> THERE'S ONL ONE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THING I LOVE
ABOUT BOTH OF YOU IS Y'ALL
AREN'T HATERS, RIGHT?
A LOT  OF, LIKE, THE OLDER
GENERATION OF PLAYERS, THEY WANT
TO BE LIKE, WE WERE THE BEST.
THIS NEW GENERATION, WE NOT --
YOU KNOW, AND I THINK THAT IT
PROBABLY IS, YOU KNOW, DIFFICULT
TO SEE THE CHANGE EGG OF THE
GUARD OF SOME THINGS, YOU KNOW,
SEEING THE NEW WAVE AND
UNDERSTANDING, OKAY, MIN IS
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT OF THE PAST.
DO YOU AGREE THAT IT'S KIND OF
HARD FOR PEOPLE TO LET GO OF
THAT,, OF THAT TIME?
>> YEAH, I THINK IT IS FOR SOME.
BUT I THINK FOR ME, YONL IF IT'S
GOOD FOR HIM, BECAUSE HE CAME IN
AS THE NUMBER ONE PICK OR
WHATEVER.
BUT I KIND OF EXPERIENCED THAT
WITH SOME OF THE OLDER PLAYERS I
PLAYED WITH AND I JUST K KIND O
MADE IT A THING LIKE I'LL NEVER
BE LIKE THAT.
I WON'T BE OLD AND BITTER.
I'M JUST GOING THE TAKEARE OF
MY BUSINESS AND WHEN THE GAME IS
DONE WITH ME, IT'S DONE WITH ME.
THAT'S FINE.
HOW I LOOK AT IT IS WE JUST
CONTINUE T TO PUSH THE BALL
FORWARD TO NOW, WHAT YOU SEE
NOW, THE SUCCESS AND THE
CONTRACTS AND DIFFERENT THINGS
LIKE THAT.
I WANT THAT FOR OUR BROTHERS.
THIS IS A FRATERNITY AND I LOOK
LEAG, THAT'S MY LITTLE IN THE
BROTHER.
ANY OF THEM CAN GET IN MY HEA
ANYTIME BECAUSE WHAT WE DONE WAS
SO RARE.
IT'S ONLY 450 OF US.
I THINK THERE WAS 400 DURING
THAT TIME.
THERE'S 30 MILLION PEOPLE THAT
HAVE NBA ASPIRATIONS AND THERE'S
ONLY 450 OF US NOW.
SO FOR , IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
ABOUT THAT CAMARADERIE AND JUST,
YOU KNOW, LOOKING AT THE PLAYERS
BEHIND ME AS JUST BEING LITTLE
BROS.
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK FOR ME,
I'M NEVER THAT HATER, AS YOU
SAY.
>> AND YOU'RE A FAN.
YOU'RE A FAN.
LIKE I WAS A FAN WHEN I WAS
PLAYING.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I'M A FAN OF THOSE GUYS.
LIKE I GET MY POPCORN AND, YOU
KNOW, MY NBA TV AND I WATCH IT
AND - YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
WATCH ALL MY FAVORITE PLAYERS.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY, YOU
DIDN'T WANT NOBODY TO TREAT YOU
LIKE THAT.
YOU DIDN'T WANT NOBODY HATING ON
YOU.
SO WHY WOULD YOU DO IT?
AND GO BACK TO WHAT I WAS
SAYING.
WHEN YOU LOOK IN THAT MIRROR, IT
DON'T LIE.
THE TRUTH IS GOING TO COME OUT.
>> YOU BEING UPSET AND B BITTER
AIN'T GOING TO STOP NOTHING.
>> YOU LOOK IN THAT MIRROR,
YOU'LL SEE THE WORD HATER RIGHT
ON YOUR FOREHEAD.
YOU HAVE TO LIVE THAT.
AND WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT THEM
BEING OUR LITTLE BROTHERS, I
LOVE THAT.
I LOVE BEING 46 YEARSLD AND
THEY COME UP TO ME AND SAID BIG
BRO AND THEY SAY UNC.
I LOOK BACK AT THE GUY THAT M ME
ME WANT TO PLAY THE GAME, LIKE
MICHAEL JORDAN.
HOW DO YOU EVER HATE ON THE MAN
THAT GAVE ME THE VISION, THAT
MADE ALLEN IVERSON WANT T TO PL
BASKETBALL AND HOW COULD I SAY
OR HATE ON HIM, LIKE, THE GUY?
AND IT WOULD BREAK MY HEART IF
HE WAS TO HATE ON ME.
AND I THINK THE SAME WAY ABOUT
HOW THE YOUNGER DUDES FEEL.
THEY GREW UP OFF OF ME.
I WOULDN'T DO IT, ANYWAY, BUT
THAT'S TERRIBLE.
>> TELL ME SOMETHING THAT A
YOUNGER PLAYER HAS COME UP AND
SAID THE WAY THEY'VE IMPACTEDD
EIR LIFE, YOU'VE NEVER SAY
BEFORE THAT REALLY STICKS WITH
YOU THAT YOU REMBER?
>> IF IT WASN'T FOR YOU, I
WOULDN'T BE HERE.
SO MANY OF THEM SAY THAT AND HOW
MUCH I INSPIRED THEM AND HOW
MUCH MY SIZE, YOU KNOW, NOT
BEING TALL ENOUGH, TALL ENOUGH,
STRONG ENOUGH, YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN, AND CAN HOW I IMPACTED
THEIR LIFE AND MADEHEIRREAM
COME TRUE, YOU KNOW, JUST BY
BELIEVING IN THEMSELVES LIKE I
BELIEVED IN MYSELF, YOU KNOW
WHAT I MEAN, AND JUST THE WHY
NOT FACTOR, WHY NOT ME?
WHY NO
YOU ONLY LIVE ONCE.
I DON'T KNOW NOBODY THAT DIED
AND CAME BACK.
AND IF I DID, I WOULD RATHER BE
ME ALL OVER AGAIN.
JUST PROBABLY A POLISHED VERSION
A LILE BIT BETTER.
THAT'S ALL.
A WAY MORE POLISHED VERSION.
>> SO WE KNOW OBVIOUSLY THE GAME
HAS EVOLVED IN A BUNCH OF WAYS.
I WANTNT YOU GUYS TO TELL ME A Y
THAT YOU LOVE THE WAY THE GAME
HAS EVOLVED AND A WAY THAT YOU
KIND OF WISH STAYED THE SAME.
>> WHAT I LIKE, I JUST LIKE T T
SKILL LEVEL OF THE GAME.
>> YEAH.
>> BECAUSE I WATCH A PLAYER DO A
IN BETWEE LIKE BETWEEN - AS
THEY SAY TWEWEENND END UP OVER
THERE.
IT'S AMAZING.
LIKE HOW DID YOU -- WHAT MADE
YOU POSSESS YOU TO TRY THAT AND
IT'S NOT A TRAVEL?
SO I REALLY LIKE HOW THE GAME
HAS EVOLVED.
AND I TRYRY TO FIGURE OUT SOMEH
NOW HOW.
GIRLS ARE DUNKING MORE.
I'M SEEING HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL, I
WATCH OVERTIME AND ALL THESE
DIFFERENT THINGS AND I'M LIKE,
HOW WILL THEY -- AND I'M
THINKING SEEING IS BELIEVING,
HOW A LOT OF KIDS SAW HIM, SO HE
DID AND IT GAVE H T
CONFIDENCE THAT THEY ENDED UP
BEING IN THE SHOW.
>> YEAH.
>> SO I JUST THINK THAT THEY
JUST -- I REALLY ENJOY HOW THE
GAME IS REALLY TRULY EVOLVING
AND REALLY JUST SITTING BACK
THINKING WHERE IS IT GOING TO
GO?
BECAUSE I'VE GOT LITTLE BOYS
THAT ARE 6 AND 4 AND I WANT THEM
TO PLAY AND I'M THINKING, WHAT
DO I START WORKING ON WITH THEM
NOW?
THERE'S SO MUCH VERSATILITY IN
THE GAME NOW.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
IMPRESSES ME ABOUT THIS
DAY .TIME.
>> I THINK I ALWAYS WONDER THIS.
IF YOU WERE PLAYING WITHH THE WY
THAT BASKETBALL IS NOW, DO YOU
THINK YOU WOULD AWAY BETTER
PLAYER, SAME PLAYER, LESS
PLAYER?
>> I WOULD -- I MEAN, JUST
BETTING ON MYSELF, I WOULD SAY
BETTER.
BETTER PLAYER.
BECAUSE IT'S MORE W WIDE OPEN.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
THE GAME IS -- IT'S A LOT MORE
WIDE HE OPEN.
BIG TIME BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT BIG
MEN THAT CAN SHOOT NOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
THAT'S WHY THE GAME HAS CHANGED.
LIKE WHAT I WAS SAYING, YOU'VE
GOT GUYS 6'9", 6'10", HE STARTED
THAT, WITH BEING A BIG M M MANH
CAN HANDLE THE BALL LIKE THAT ON
THE PERIMETER.
BUT YOU'VE GOT KD, SEVEN FEET
AND HE HANDLES THE BALL LIKE A
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
HOWO YOU GUARD KD?
>> YOU DON'T.
STEPH CURRY, HE'S DIFFERENT.
THAT'S WHAHA I LOVE, THE
EVOLUTION OF THE GAME.
SEEING IT CHANGED SO MUCH.
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT MY HANDLING
AND STUFF LIKE THAT.
I WAS NOT HANDLING THE BALL LIKE
STEPH AND KYRIE.
THEY ARE DOING OUT OF THIHIS WOD
THINGS WITH THE BALL.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
BUT IN THIS NEW WAVE, I WOULD
JUST THINK THAT I WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN BETTER.
AND, YOU KNOW, DID SOME OF THE
THINGS OR EVEN MORE THAN I WAS
DOING TH.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LIKE NOW, WHEN I WASPLAYING,
YOU KNOW, WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE
AND I CAME OUT, MY TEAMMATES
USED TO ALWAYS SAY, WELL, YOU
KNOW, CHUCK, YOU GET TO THE
LEAGUE, THEY CAN'T IRAN BOX AND
ONE ON YOU.
THEY CAN'T RUN ANY ZONES ON YOU.
AND IT'S DOWN THE THIRD AND I'M
LIKE, MAN, THAT'S RIGHT, THEY
HAVE TO PLAY ME ONENE-ON-ONELL
GAME, I'M GOING TO HAVE 40 EVERY
NIGHT.
FOUR SCORING TITLE NECESSARY AND
ALL O A SUDDEN NOW THEY'VE GOT
ZONES NOW.
ALL THESE GIMMICK DEFENSES.
NOW THEY DOUBLE-TEAM AND EVERY
TIME.SOMEBODY TOUCH THE BALL.
I MIGHT HAVE HAD SOMETHING TO DO
WITH THEM GOING BACK TO THE ZONE
BECAUSE YOU REMEMBER HOW IN THE
NB IT WAS NEVER -- YOU COULD
NEVER PLAY ZONE.
>> UNTIL YOU STARTED K KILLING.
>> ONE-ON-ONE, YOU'VE GOTHIS
DUDE, SIX FEET, 165 POUNDS WITH
SCORING TITLES ALONE NOW.
>> S SO WE' GOING TO CHANGE THE
RULES ALL THE WAY.
>> CORRECT.
>> NOW YOU CAN RUN A ZONE.
>> AND YOU KNOW, I PLAYED IN THE
EAST SO WE PLAYED INITIALLY IN
THE PLAYOFFS, I FELT LIKE MY
FIRST THREE YEARS.
AND IT USED TO GET SO BAD IN THE
FILM SESSION, YOU KNOW WHAT?
LET HIM SCORE.
>> BUT IT'S SO CRAZY TOHINK
ABOUT THINGS THAT ARE KIND OF
LIKEKE THE AI RULE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LIKE THAT REALLY CAN BE ONE.
WE ALSO KNO DRESS CODE, LIKE
THOSE THINGS, LIKE, THE IMPACT
TH YOU HAD, THE THINGS THAT
CHANGED YOU BECAUSE OF YOUR
PRESENCE IS JUST -- I THINK
REALLY COOL AND JUST SPEAK SO
MUCH TO THE LEGACY.
YOU SEE HOW DOPE IT IS?
I MEAN, MAY HE REST IN PEACE,
WITH HIM CHANGING THE DRESS
CODE, IT WAS LIKE -- I MEAN, IT
WAS LIKE YOU TAKING THE IDENTITY
OF THESE PEOPLE AWAY.
NOBODY PLAYED THE SAMAME.
WE DON'T PLAY THE SAME.
WE DON'T LOOK THE SAME.
WHY SHOU WE DRESS THE SAME?
AND MY MENTALITY WAS ALWAYS --
WHEN I WAS COMING IN MY ROOKIE
YEAR, I WAS LIKE BICALLY NOW I
CAN BUY ALL THE CLOTHES THAT THE
GUYS AROUND MY WAY WANT BECAUSE
I CAN AFFORD IT NOW.
WHEN I WAS LEAVING THE ARENA, I
WAS GOING TO THE CLUB.
I WASN'T GOING TO CHURCH OR --
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
COMING UP WHERE I'M FROM, WHEN
YOU WORE A SUIT, YOU WERE
WEARING A SUIT TO THE CHURCH OR
A FUNERAL OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
AND MY WHOLEHING WAS WHEN
EVERYBODY SAW ME DRESSING THE
WAY I WAS DRESSING LIKE I WANTED
TO, LIKE -- AND EVERYBODY
STARTED DOING IT, THE NBA WAS
LIKE, HOLD ON, YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN?
AND IT GAVE US -- AND I KNOW
WHAT IT WAS.
IT WAS KIND OF A THUG LOOK.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
WHEN EVERYBODY WAS WEARING
SUITS.
WHEN I CAME UP, I NEVER WORE NO
SUIT TO THE PARK TO GO PLAY
BASKETBALL.
I WORE A SWEAT SUIT OR WHATEVER.
THE PERSON.CLOTHES DON'T MAKAKE
>> NO, NO, NO.
WHEN PEOPLE GO ROB A BANK AND
ALL THTHAT, WHAT DID THEY HAVE ?
SUITS.
OKAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
AND NOW IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
YOU MIGHT NOT LIKE WHAT THESE
GUYS ARE WEARING, BUT IT'S
BEAUTIFUL.
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T EXPRESSING
THEMSELVLVES THE WAY THEY WANT .
>> IT'SS SO GOOD.
I LOVE THE FASHION.
>> I LIKE EVERYBODY ON THEIR
OWN -- THEY GOT THEIR OWN WAG
SWAG AND OWN PERSONALS.
I LOVE IT.
>> YOU LOOK BACK AND YOU THINK
WHY, HOW BAD THAT, HOW BAD WE
NEED TO CHANGE PEOPLE BECAUSE WE
FELT SO UNSURE ABOUT ONE PERSON.
>> PEOPLE A ALWAYS SCARED OF
IT.
BUT IF IT MAKES YOU
UNCOMFORTABLE IN ANY WAY, YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IT,
ESPECIALLYHEN YOU'RE A HIGH
POWER.
I WANTED TO LOOK LIKE MICHAEL
JORDAN ON THE COURT.
I WANTED TO LOOK LIKE A
SUPERHERO.
LIKE I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY GUYS
RIGHT W WEAR DIFFERENT COLOR
SHOES IN THEIR UNIFO.
BUT THAT'S THEIR COLOR.
I ALWAYS LOOKED AT WHAT SUPERMAN
WORE RED, YELLOW ANDLUE.
BAT MON WORE YELLOW AND BLACK.
SPIDER-MAN WORE RED AND BLACK
AND BLUE.
>> BUT IT WAS WEIRD, TOO, WITH
THE WHOLE THUG THING, RIGHT?
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT, WE WERE
WEARING $1500 SES.
>> SUITS.
>> WHY DOES IT HAVE TO BE A THUG
WHEN I'M WEARING SOMETHING --
THEY NEVER SN A DO RAG IN A
HAT.
AND IT GOT SCARY.
BUT THEY WOULD AIR BRUSH MY
TATTOOS ON.
I REMEMBER THOSE THINGS
HAPPENING.
>> WHICH IS WILD.
>> LIKE THEY'RE TAKING PARTS OF
YOU --
>> YEAH.
WE WANT TO SUMMON YOU.
WE WANT YOUR GAME.
WE DON'T WANT THE CORN ROWS.
WE DON'T WANT THETATTOOS.
BUT EVERYTHING ELSE, WE COOL
WITH.
AND EVERYBODY WAS MAKING A BIG
DEAL ABOUT MY CORN ROWS.
LIKE I WAS JUST -- ARE WE --
>> YEAH.
>> I WAS TIRED OF PEOPLE PUCKING
MY HAIR UP ON THE ROAD.
I JUST BLOW MY HAIR OUT AND GET
CORN ROWS, THEN I DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THAT.
THAT WAS THE ONLY REASON I DID
IT.
IT DIFFERENT HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH ME TRYING TO LOOK LIKIKE A
THUG.
I WAS TID OF PEOPLE MESSING MY
HAIR UP.
>> ONE THING WE GREW OUT OF,
IT'S --
>> PARTY IS OVER.
>> MY TEAMMATES USED TO GET MAD
AS HELL AT ME.
I USED TO GO INTO BIG AND TALL
AND BOUGHT EVERYTHING UP.
>> WAIT, YOU WENT INTO BIG AND
TALL?
>> I DID.
I'M TALKING ABOUT BIG MEN ON THE
TEAM.
AFTER PRACTICE, I WOULD BEAT
THEM THERE AND I WOULDUY
EVERYTHING.
THEY WANT COME IN THERE AND GET
MAD AT ME BECAUSE I WOULD BUY UP
ALL THE BIG CLOTHES.
>> DID YOU JUST LIKE THE LOO
>> IT WAS IN STYLE.
AND PROBABLY I HAD THE LITTLE
MAN COMPLEX BECAUSE I ALWAYS
WANTED THE BIGGEST CAR.
I WAS 165 THEN.
SO I WANTED THE BIGGEST CLOTHES.
I DIDN'T WANT TO LOOK SMALL.
IT WAS JUST THE GUYS IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD USED TO LOOK LIKE
THAT.
>>
>> YOU SAID I'M NOT A POINT
GUARD, I'M A KILLER.
TELL ME FIVE GUYS PLAYING RIGHT
NOW THAT YOU'RE LIKE, THEY'RE
KILLERS.
>> STEPH CURRRRY, KAVEN DURANT,
JAMES HARDEN -- JAMES HARDEN --
>> WHAT'S THE SMILE FOR?
>> BECAUSE I KNOW A LOT OF
KILLERS.
BRADLEY BEAL IS A KILLER.
OH, DAME.
DAME IS THE KILLER.
>> CERTIFIED.
>> DANE IS A MONSTER WITH IT.
STEPH IS JUST BAD AS HELL.
BUT DAME JUST A RUDE MOTHER --
HE'S JUST RUDE.
HE'S DISRESPECTFUL.
HE JUST DO ANYTHING, PASS
HALF-COURT AND LET IT FLY.
LIKE NO FEAR.
HE'S NOT JUST A KILLER, HE'S A
SERIAL KILLER.
>> BIG SHOUT OUT TO DAME.
SPEAKING OF DAME, I ALSO ASKED
DAME IF HE HAD A QUESTION FOR
YOU AND I HAVE ONE FROM HIM, AS
WELL, WHICH MAKES MEHINK OF
ANOTHER ONE OF YOUR QUOTES WHICH
IS WHEN SOMEONE ASKED YOU ABOUT
COACHING YOU SAID I AIN'T
COACHING BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
COCOACH N MOTHER -- THAT MAKE
MORE MONEY THAN ME.
>> RIT.
>> DOES THAT STAND?
>> YEAH.
IT'S LIKE I ALWAYS HAVEHE -- I
HAVE THE UTMOST RESPECT FOR
COACHES IN THE NBA.
BUT COACHES WORLDWIDE, BUT IN
THE NBA IT'S TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THESE GUYS
MAKING ALL THIS MONEY, EVERYBODY
ON THE TEAM MAKING MORE MONEY
THAN YOU.
AND YOU'RE ABLE TO BRING THESE
GUYS TOGETHER AND GET THEM TO
PLAY THE RIGHT WAY AND HAVING
THEM ALL WITITH THE SAME MIND-S
AND THE SAME GOAL IN THEIR HEAD
AND THEY BUY IN IT TO ULTIMATEL
WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP.
THAT'S POWER AND THAT'S RESPECT.
WHEN YOU'VE GOT THESE GUYS.
THEY PROBABLY FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE THE MAN.
BUT SOMEHOW, SOME WAY, TO MAKE
IT ALL WORK, THEHEY FIT IN A RO,
PLAY THEIR ROLE AND ALL THE
SUCCESS COMES AND THAT ONE GUY
THAT IS LEADING THEM, YOU KNOW
WHAT I MEAN?
SUPPOSED TO GET HIS FLOWERS.
>> I'LL READ DAME'S QUESTION TO
YOU AND SEE IF THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU WOULD BE INTERESTED IN.
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT JUST
TRAINING CURRENT PLAYERS, NOT
FULL TIME, BUT JUST WORKING WITH
IT?
>> I WOULD LOVE THAT AND I WOULD
LOVE -- I'M GLAD YOU ASKED ME
THAT.
>> SHOUT OUT TO DAME.
>> DEFINITELY SHOUT OUT TO DAME.
>> I DON'T WANT TO SAY NOTHING
TOO BAD.
YOU KNOW WHO I'M TALKING TO.
BUT I'D RATHE HELP
I KNOW -- I'VE FORGOTTEN M MORE
BASKETBALL THAN SOME PEOPLE
KNOW.
AND I KNOW I CAN HELP AN
ORGANIZATION IS G BETTER.
I KNOW SO MANY OF THE INS AND
OUTS OF BASKETBALL AND NOT JUST
TALENTWISE.
BUT I KNOW OTHER THINGS WHEN IT
COMES TO BASKETBALL.
I KNOW THINGS INSIDE OF
MIGHT NOT KNOW THAT I  PEOPLE
EXPERIENCED THROUGHOUT MY CAREER
AND THROUGHOUT MY LIFE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I CAN GET ON A BASKETBALL COURT
AND TELL IF SOMEBODY IS SCARED
OF M M MY BY JUST LOOKINGT THEM.
I CAN LOOK AT YOUR DEMEANOR AND
SEE THAT YOU DON'T WANT TO
NIGHT.
MAYBE TONIGHT OR THE NIGHT
BEFORE, BUT NOT TONIGHT.
AND I KNOW SO MANY THINGS, DO
THEY HAVE A PROBLEM, WHAT MAKES
THEM PLAY A CERTAIN WAY, ARE
THEY A CERTAIN WAY THROUGH THIS
QUARTER, THE NEXT ONE, THE NEXT
ONE OR THE NEXT ONE.
HOW THEY THEY ARE IN OVERTIME.
AND THE BALL FEEL LIKE A HOT
POTATO IN THEIR HAND.
DO THEY WANT IT?
JUST BEHIND THE SCENES, I KNOW I
CAN HELP A LOT OF ATHLETES.
>> YOU DON'T PLAY TO BE
SPECIFIC?
>> I'M A SIXER FOR LIFE.
SO EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT I WANT
TO HELP THE ORGANIZATION.
I'VE BEEN RETIRED, WHAT, 11
YEARS?
>> UH-HUH.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW I'M NOT A
PART OF THAT STAFF SOME KIND OF
WAY.
>> ALMOST LIKE A CONSULTANT.
THAT WOULD BE REALLY NICE.
>> EVEN IF IT WAS THTHAT.
EVEN IF IT WAS THAT.
I WOULD BE --
>> HIRE HIM.
>> I WOULD BE THE HAPPIEST IN
THE WORLD.
AND THE MONEY THING AIN'T GOT
NOTHING T TO DO WH I IT.
DON'T KNOW WHY NOTHING HAS
BEEN PUT IN PLACE.
BUT IT'S SOMETHING I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
>> EVERYONE GETS SO EXCITED.
THEY WANT TO SOAK UP THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT YOU HAVE.
>> I KNOW I CAN'T COME IN HERE
DRESSING LIKE THIS.
>> THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
>> THAT IS THE PROBLBLEM.
>> BUT IT IS THAT, THEN ADDRESS
IT.
ADDRESS IT.
I DON'T HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
HAVING NO CONTRACT WITH
STIPULATIONS IN MY CONTRACT.
I DON'HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH NO
CLOSET IN MY STUFFING.
AND IT'S UP TO ME TO ACCEPT IT
OR NOT.
>> AND WHAT THEY WANT GAIN FROM
HAVING YOU --
>> WE'RE GOING TO GET YOU A JOB.
>> RIGHT NOW IT'S A WAT SHE
THE SHETD MOMENT WHERE WE SEE
YOUNGER GENERATIONS COMING UP.
SO WE'LL START WITH JAYSON
TATUM.
>> WHAT LIKEE ABO HIS GAME IS
HE DOES EVERYTHING REALLY WELL.
I JUST THINK -- I'M LOOKING ME
FROM A LEADERSHIP STANDPOINT
FROM HIM.
HE CONTROLS THAT ORGANIZATION
AND TAKES THAT NUMBER STEP.
YOYOUEAR A LOT OF COMPARISONSF
KBE AND DIFFERENT THINGS LIKE
THAT.
THOSE ARE HUGE SHOES TO FILL.
SOS WHAT I SEE FROM HIM IS I
THINK HE WILL TAKE IT TO THE
NEXT LEVEL.
>> I RESPECT WHAT AL IS SAYING.
AL IS LOOKING AT IT FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE.
IT'S AL HARRINGTON, SO OBVIOLY
YOU HAVE TO TAKE IT FOR WHAT IT
IS.
AS FAR AS EVERYTHING ELSE, I
DON'T SEE NOTHINGG WRONG.
I MEAN, I DON'T SEE NOTHING
WRONG.
HE'S IN THAT KILR CATEGORY,
DEFINITELY.
THERE I NOTHING THAT HE CAN'T
DODO O THE BASKETBALL COURT.
SO IF THERE'S ANYTHING THAT HE
MIGHT NEED TO IMPROVE ON,
OBVIOUSLY IT HAS TO BE SOMETHING
IN THE LOCKER ROOM OR SOMETHING.
CRUISE CONTROL.
NEVER LOOKS RATTLED.
TREY YOUNG.
>> AGAIN, I DON'T -- AND HE'S A
LEADER.
AND THEY LISTEN THIM.
ALL I WOULD SAY IS KEEP DOING
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
I DON'T SEE NO FLAWS IN YOUR
GAME AT ALL.
>> AND YOU CAN TELL ME WHAT YOU
LIKE ABOUT THEIR GAME.
>> I LIKE EVERYTHING IN HIS
GAME.
>> HE'S STEPH CURRY 2.0.
>> JUST SHORTER.
>> A LITTLE BIT MORE SWAG TO
HOLD ON.
WHO GOT A LITTLE BIT MORE SWAG?
>> I THINK TREY DO.
>> STEPH HAS A LOT OF SWAG.
>> YEAH.
TREYCRAZY.
I WAS IN NEW YORK, THOUGH.
NEW YORK, PHILADELPHIA, THEY'RE
GOING TO GIVE IT TO YOU.
SO HE HAD NO CHOICE.
BUT TO INTERACT WITH THEM.
>> BUT I DON'T THINK STEPH WOULD
HAVE DID THAT.
>> TREY ACCEPTED THAT VILLAIN
ROLE.
HE WOULD GO INTO THESE ARENAS
AND HE WOULD BE THE VILLAIN.
STEPH HAS A LOT OF SWAG.
HE WAS GOING IN AS T GUY WHO
WAS GOING TO SHOOTOT T LIGHTS
OUT.
WHAT ABOUT JOHN MORAN?
ANOTHER YOUNG GUY.
>> THE ONLY THING YOU PROBABLY
COULD -- THAT'S THE ONLY -- AND
HE CAN MAKE THAT.
SO I'M JUST SAYING MORE.
>> HE'S TROUBLE RIGHT NOW.
>> ALL THE POINTS.
>> AND HE'S A KILLER IN A
DIFFERENT WAY BECAUSE HE CAN DO
IT IN A POINT GUARD STYLE.
YOU CAN DO IT ALL KINDS OF WAYS
WITH ASSISTS, WITHCORING.
HE GOT THE WHOLE PACKAGE.
>> THE NBA IS IN GOOD HANDS.
ADAM SILVER --
>> IN GOOD HANDS.
>> AND MORE SO, STANDING OVATION
FOR THE FANS.
FOR THE NS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
THEY GOT T -- THE PRORODUCT IS
THERE ON THE FLOOR.
IT'S GOOD FOR YEARS TO COME.
THE GAMES ARE GREAT.
THE FANS ARE BACK IN THE STANDS.
AND FOR ALL OF US FANS, WE BACK.
>> I LOVE IT.
ONE MORE YOUNGUY.
LUKA.
>> HE'S IN MY TOP FIVE.
>> TOP FIVE IN THE LEAGUE PERIOD
RIGHT NOW?
>> YEAH.
>> THEN YOU'VE GOT TO NAME YOUR
WHOLE TOP FIVE.
AND DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> LUKA IS CRAZY.
>> I WAS ONLY ABLE TO NAME FIVE
KILLERS .
>> YEAH, YOU WERE.
BUT YOU SAID THERE WAS A BUNCHC
OF KILLERS.
SOME OFOUR FAVORITES.
>> WHAT I LIKE ABOUT HIM SO MUCH
IS HE JUST PLAYS THE GAME.
HE'S FEARLESS.
HOT POTATO AND ALL OFTHAT,
AIN'T NONE OF THAT IN HIM.
>> HE'S BUSTING IT EVERY SINGLE
NIGHT.
IT DON'T MATTER.
YOU CAN PUT YOUR BEST DEFENDER
ON HIM.
HE'S TOP FIVE.
AND I DON'T WANT TO GET THRHROUH
MY TOP FIVE.
>> WE HAVE TO KNOW WHO IS IN.
YOU NEED THE CONTEXT.
>> SO YOU'VE GOT KD.
YOU'VE GOT GIANNIS.
>> OH, MAN.
OH, MAN.
>> THAT MEANS I CAN SLIDE
ANTHONY DAVIS BACK IN THERE.
>> FOR TOP FIVE.
>>.
>> STAEPH CURRY.
>> AND LUKA, RIGHT?
>> NO JAMES?
AVERAGING MICHAEL JORDAN
NUMBS, 36 AND SCORING TITLE
AFTER SCORING TITLE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT KILLERS NOW.
>> JAMES IS IN IT BECAUSE I
THROW JAMES AND SOMETIMES I HAVE
KAWHI.
KAWHI THROWS ME OFF BECAUSE HE
DON'T PLAY ENOUGH GAMES.
>> I LOVE LUKA.
HE ALREADY IN THE TOP FIVE.
>> AND THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
JAMES HAS BEEN HURT LIKE THIS.
THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER, HE WAS
ALWAYS AVAILABLE.
BUT, YEAH, LUKA, I MEAN, HE'S A
KILLER.
HE'S GOT TO -- HE PROBABLY HAS A
CULT, MA
>> AOU IN PRETTY GOOD
AGREEMENT WITH HIS TOP FIVE?
>> NO.
>> OKAY.
NAMEOURS.
>> I ALREADY NAMED THEM.
>> SO YOUR KILL REMEMBERS YOUR
TOP FIVE?
>> YEAH.
>> SO YOU HAVE TO PUTAMES IN
THERE.
>> SO WOULD YOU GO JAMES OR
ANTHONY DAVIS?
>> AS FAR AS KILLERS?
>> YEAH.
>> I'M GOING WITH JAMES.
ARE YOU CRAZY?
HOW MUCH SCORING TITLES --
>> I AIN'T GOT NONE.
>> WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PUTTING
THE BALL IN THE BASKET.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> KILLERS.
>> A COUPLE MORE BEFORE I LET
YOU GO.
I'M CURIOUS FORYOU, WHO RIGHT
NOW KIND OF FEELS LIKE THE MOST
AI?
>> DO I WANT TO SAY?
JA?
>> YEAH, I LIKE JA.
>> TO ME, JA REPRESENTNTS H HOP
AND ALL THAT.
FOR ME, EVERY TIME I SEE HIM, I
SEE LITTLE BABIES.
>> AND JOHN IS JUST COOL.
>> AND THEN I WOULD S I LIKE
TO -- WHEN I COMPARE, LIKE,
CAN'T NEVER COMPARE NOBODY TME
LIKE THAT.
BECAUSE THEY'RE NEVER MY SIZE.
LIKE EVERYBODY ALWAYS -- LIKE
THEY'LL HAVE A CATEGORY AND THEY
WILL BE LIKE THE BEST LITTLE MAN
AND I SEEN IT, YOU KNOW, ON TV
THE OTHER DAY AND I WASN'T UP
THERE.
STEPH KCURRY IS NOT A LITTLE MA
AT 6'3".
WHEN YOU TRY TO COMPARE
SOMETHING TO ME, THERE'S NOBODY
MY SIZE TO WHERE I CAN SAY,
OKAY, HE GETS BUCKETS AND HE'LL
BANG IT, TOO.
THAT IS WHAT I BE IN HERE.
WHEN I THINK OF SOMEBODY, IT
ALWAYS HAS TO BEOMEBODY THAT
IS THREE OR FOUR INCHES TALLER
THAN ME.
SO IT'S HARD TO, YOU KNOW, PUT
ME IN A CATEGORY LIKE, YOU KNOW,
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, WHAT
PERSON SIXEET IN THE LEAGUE
THAT IS GOING TO GIVE I IT TYOU.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
THE ONLY PERSON I CAN THIHINK O
IS ISAIAH.
AT BOSTON BEFORE H HEOT HURT.AR
AND THE YEAR BEFORE THAT, AND
THEN I LOOK AT IIAH TO WHERE
HE COULD BE ISAIAH AND EVERYBODY
ELSE FOLLOW HIM.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
BECAUSE HE WENT CLEVELAND AND
THEN HE -- WHO WAS ATT CLEVELAN?
THEN HE WENT TO L.A., LeBRON IS
THERE.
THEN HE WENT TO --
>> NEW ORLEANS.
AND THEN THEY GOT THREE STARS
ALREADY.
SO HE WAS NEVER PUT IN A
SITUATIONR JUST A SITUATION TO
WHERE HE WOULD SUCCEED.
AND SHOUT OUT TO EYE A ISAIAH.
STILL ROOTING FOR YOU.
IF ANYBODY CAN GET THROUGH THIS,
YOU CAN.
AND STAY UP, STAY STRONG,
BELIEVE IN YOURSELF AND BELIEVE
IN GOD.
>> THEY'RE WANTING ME TO WRAP
UP.
I DO HAVE ONE MORE FOR YOU GUYS.
I ALSO NEED TO SAY I WAS ENJOYED
THIS SO MUCH JUST SOAK UP ALL
THIS BASKETBALL FROM YOU GUYS
AND HEARING YOU TALK ABOUT LIFE
AND EVERYTHING YOU'VE LEARNED.
IT'S
IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE FOR ME.
>> YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THE
PERSON THAT IS ASKING THE
QUESTIONS.
IT CAN BE REAL BORING IF YOU'RE
NOT ASKG THE RIGHT STUFF.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> BUT IT CAN BE GREAT IF YOU'RE
ASKING THEIGHT THINGS.
>> I APPRECIATE THAT.
>> AND NOT THE SAME THINGS THAT
EVERYBODY ELSE ASKS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> I'VE E BEEN DOI THIS FOR 25,
26 YEARS AND I GET THE SAME
QUESTIONS AND THE SAME STUFF ALL
THE TIME.
SO IT'S GOOD THAT THROW SOME --
YOU KNOW, MAKE A POT OF GUM BOW,
THERE.OME DIFFERENT STUFF UP IN
>> THAT IS SUCH HIGH PRAISE.
I APPRECIATE THAT SO MUCH.
WE HAVE A POTD OF GUMBO.
BUT I HAVE ONE MORE FOR YOU
GUYS.
I THINK IT'S COOL TO SEE THE
DIFFERENT STAGES OF LIFE YOU'VE
SEEN ON THE COURT AND OFF THE
COURT.
YOU HAVE SEEN SO MUCH.
>> OPEN BOOK.
>> YEAH.
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE NOW A
BUSINESSMAN, YOU'VE LEARNED SO
MUCH.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW THROUGH LIFE
WHAT YOU CREDIT YOUR RESILIENCY
TO AND WHAT HAS ALLOWED YOU TO,
YOU KNOW, STAY YOU THROUGHOUT
ALL OF THIS.
BOTH OF YOU.
>> I WILL PROBABLY BE QUICK.
IT WAS ALL MY UPBRINGING, YOU
KNOW?
MY CLOSE-KNIT FAMILY, MY MOM WAS
THE SUPERHERO IN MY FAMILY.
MY DAD DIED YOUNG WHEN I WAS
YOUNG, WHEN HE WAS YOUNG.
AND THE RELATIONSHIP THAT ME AND
MY MOTHER, THE BOND WE BUILT
FROM THERE ISS WHO I AM TODAY.
AND IT'S JUST -- I'M THE SAME
PERSON.
THE FOUNDATION THAT MY MOM LAID,
INTEGRITY, WHAT IS RIGHT IS
RIGHT AND WHAT IS WRONG IS
WRONG.
THAT'S KIND OF HOW I LIVE MY
I THINK THAT'S WHY I AM WHO I AM
TODAY.
>> I LOVE THAT.
I LOVE THAT ABOUT Y.
>> MY FAMILY.
MY FAMILY, BEING THERE FOR ME,
ME CARING SO MUCH ABOUT THEM AND
WANTING TO BE ABLE TO CREATE A
BETTER LIFE FOR THEM.
AND THE SECOND PART WAS WHAT?
>> HOW YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO STAY
YOU THROUGHOUT EVERYTHING, EVEN
IFAD THINGS HAVE HAPPENED.
>> ISEASY.
THAT'S BEEN THE EASIEST PART FOR
ME.
IS BEING THE SAME PERSON THAT
THE PEOPLE THAT LOVE ME AND THE
PEOPLE THAT I LOVE ARE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE ALL THE TIME, NO
MATTER WHAT, THE UPS AND DOWNS,
HOW MUCH MONEY, HOW MUCH FAME,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
JUST WANTING TO BE THAT, AS
WELL, AND FEENG LIKE THERE'S
NOTHING WRONG WITH IT.
SO THERE WAS NEVER A POINT WHERE
I FELT LIKE SELLINGUT AND
BECOMING SOMETHING THAT I'M NOT.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN BEING MEAN TO
SOMEBODY.
I LE WHEN -- BEING NICE IS
COOL, TOO
I LOVE WHEN A MOTHER -- MEETS ME
LIKE I THOUGHT YOU WOULD BE.THI
YOU N'T JUDGE ME IF YOU'VE
NEVER MET ME.
SOMEBODY ELSE CAN HAVE CAN A
DIFFERENT OPINION OF ME BECAUSE
MITT THEM.CUMSTANCES OF WHEN I
I TELL YOU THAT THIS IS NOT THE
RIGHT TIME, CAN YOU WAIT UNTIL I
FINISH THIS AND THE PERSON --
WELL -- YOU, MAN, YOU AIN'T
BETTER THAN KOBE BRYANT, ANYWAY.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, I DON'T
WATCH BASKETBALL, MOTHER -- YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
AND THEN YOUSK THEM ABOUT
ALLAN IVERSON A WEEK LATER AND
THEY SAY, WELL, HE' AN -- HOLE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I ASKEDIM TO TAKE A PICTURE OR
WHATEVER AND HE WOULDN'T'T DO I.
BUT THEY AIN'T GOING TO LEAVE
THE PART OUT THAT HE WAS FEEDING
HIS DAUGHTER OR WHATEVER.
>> THEY TELL HALF THE STORY.
>> YES.
>> I'M HAPPYHAT WE WERE ABLE
TO GIVE THE FULL STORY.
I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH.
>> I HAVE AN UPDATE, TO